that crash has brought up some really
painful memories for a local family it's
been about five months since walter
anderson was killed in a similar crash
so today anderson's family is speaking
out saying enough is enough christian
casada spoke to the family and joins us
live in studio with their message
tonight kristen well denise and brian we
spoke to walter alderman's sister who is
grieving months later she thinks the
pain will never go away as long as drunk
people keep getting behind the wheel and
destroying lives
it's not just one person that died the
family a part of them dies with them
it's been about five months since walter
alderman was killed his sister
antoinette still coping with that pain
but picking up the phone to call him
it's just like you know a reflex and you
realize he's gone and he's gone forever
and it's it's sad according to reports
33 year old andrew rodriguez was going
141 miles per hour in a rented
lamborghini on russell road just before
midnight on june 5th seconds before
crashing into a moped alderman was
driving
alderman says tuesday's fatal dui crash
involving raiders player henry ruggs and
23-year-old tina tintor brings back
painful memories and claims one thing is
to blame it's our laws our laws are too
lacks these people get away with doing
stuff i mean maybe if there was stricter
laws and stricter penalties and you sat
in jail for a while instead of getting
out on bail maybe you would think before
you drunk drink and drive alderman says
rodriguez and ruggs were wealthy with
bright futures but it was that dangerous
decision she says that would have
allowed her brother and tintour a chance
to live
i pray he didn't know what hit him and i
pray the same thing for that family
because that's the part you worry about
my god did they even know what was
happening
rodriguez posted bail back in june and
is on a high level electric monitoring
back in texas where he lives he's due
back in court on january 6. christian
cassette is live local now